nous sommes à courbevoie une banlieue de
paris que tatiana s'apprête à quitter
définitivement
il y à un mois et demi elle a décidé de
s'engager pour devenir l'une des toutes
premières femmes fusiliers commandos de
l'armée de l'air une carrière militaire
réservé jusqu alors aux hommes et à eux
seuls après six semaines de classe à
saintes première ferme chez maman mais
dès demain les choses sérieuses vont
commencer un mois de formation à dijon
pour devenir commando
ça m'intéressait pas du tout de rester
dans un bureau sa journée choisie
fusiliers commandos d'accord ça va être
plus dur mais c'est plus intéressant
messieurs je reste dans un bureau sage
pour les scènes en restant à l'école
la maman du tatiana ne cautionne pas
l'engagement de sa fille mais elle ne
respecte même pas les militaires donc
mais on
sait ce qu'elle veut donc elle a le
droit d'aimer
j'irai pas sont contre toute façon je
mettais à son encontre
pour fuir la monotonie d'un quotidien à
l'avenir incertain tatiana et sa cousine
ont décidé de s'engager elles ont signé
pour quatre ans en échange de 6000
francs de salaire surprise dans la cité
vous connaissez et qui
c'est vrai qu'on s'est engagé dans
l'armée
ils nous ont pris pour des folles
pour les mecs là donc vous allez cher
non cela remet à 1 à faire ça
gèle à prouver à personne c'est à moi
qu'il faut je le prouve je peux
je peux réussir à ce que j'ai envie de
faire
gare de lyon tatiana retrouve sa cousine
stéphanie 18 ans
élevé comme deux soeurs elles ont
toujours tout partagé aujourd'hui c'est
encore ensemble qu'elles prennent le
même train pour emprunter la même voie
mais si les deux cousines rêve d'une vie
d'action d'une vie qui bouge d' aventure
pour l'instant leur seul souci est de ne
pas être séparés
je vais dans la même chambre
parce que là fait qu'on arrive dans les
dernières en plus c'est pas se mettre
dans la bouche mais à mon avis en tête
qu'est-ce que depuis le début vous êtes
dans la même chambre puis s'est toujours
arrangé
la même brigade d'achat
on est toujours un temps
19 heures arrivé sur la base aérienne
102 de dijon
sabrina déjà en tenue de combat accueil
tatiana et stéphanie ces trois drôles de
dames font partie du même escadron même
de nuit elle ne passe pas inaperçu et
provoque la curiosité de leurs futurs
frères d'armes
les débuts sur la base s'annonce bien
pour les cousines leur voeu est exaucé
elle partage la même chambre
au total les filles sont 13 dans la
promotion 13 parmi cent quatre-vingt dix
garçons elles sont logées dans les mêmes
bâtiments
première obligation dès l'arrivée sur
base ont filé le treillis le signe
d'appartenance à un monde dont les
règles sont différentes terminée la
coquetterie la mode ici est au
camouflage
de stern avait sa propre aux
bas après je sais pas du tout on va les
percevoir mode ranger
j'adore petit
bateau si oui
j'imagine il aux agents bras tu joues
nom des gens pensaient qu'on allait être
à plusieurs enfin j'en à plusieurs ont
pensé qu'on allait plus nombreux
et puis voilà pendant mon cul c'est des
mecs à laitages
c'est pas du tout comme un centre
promotion 90e 2 5
bonjour au poids séibou
alors touchant je serai à me présenter
je suis le capitaine au commandant
l'escadron de fichiers commando r je
vous souhaite la bienvenue vous êtes sur
la base aérienne 102 guillemer de dijon
comme ça vous repérer quand vous allez
vous perdre dans le train et vous serez
ou revenir
ça va être désormais votre maison votre
centre d'instruction pendant quatre
semaines et trois jours il va falloir
que vous travaillez que vous adoptiez
aux règles l'honneur de devoir et le
service vous êtes des jeunes femmes des
hommes des jeunes hommes qui dans
quelques semaines auront des armes dans
les mains
donc nous devons être sûrs de vos
compétences de votre probité c'est à
dire de votre honnêteté et ceux qui ne
rempliraient pas ces conditions
ne pouvons pas faire partie de notre
profession j'espère que c'est bien
deux semaines plus tard nous sommes à
mi-chemin de la période d'instruction
la la la la la
non seulement tu ferais un mois c'est
parti l'entraînement est le même pour
les filles que pour les garçons au
programme ce matin combats au corps à
corps mélenchon
4 semaines de formation les instructeurs
ont peu de temps pour fabriquer des
militaires
la formation doit être rapide objectif
pour l'année 2002 recruter 3500
fusiliers commandos
tatiana n'éprouve aucune difficulté dans
sa nouvelle vie chaque jour elle
progresse les garçons elles les affronte
sans problème
stéphanie en revanche moins forte
mentalement commence à éprouver
certaines difficultés
[Musique]
quand tu arrives pas regardes tu ici ok
ah bon 2 ça va c'est pas deux quand tu
frappes
tu feras fais-tu va pas lui faire mal
d'accord si tu frappes sur lui je dis
pas de rentrer comme une brute mais là
je te vois tu es comme ça l'a jamais
tombé sur un gars va falloir réagir
qu'est ce que tu vas lui faire sans lui
ça lui fait absolument rien je vois ce
que je veux dire le problème c'est que
quand l europe à part les filles qu'on
fait des sports de combat c'est que bon
il ya un problème évident au déjà de
force physique donc on essaie d'adopter
sa par rapport à ce problème là quoi
mais c'est vrai que on essaye de le
déployer cette agressivité là on le voit
quand elle fait son mouvement déjà
apprendre la gestuelle c'est déjà
difficile bon pour la télé mais on
essaye vraiment quelle qu'elles envoient
quoi parce que si jamais elle tombe face
à quelqu'un d'autre voie que leurs
agissements au cours des semaines le
caractère et la résistance des apprentis
soldats se révèle à gauche sandra 21 ans
43 kg à droite tatiana 19 ans 58 kg
aujourd'hui elles combattent ensemble
c'est exceptionnel sans entraînement
leur nez ensemble mais à revendre et
avec un médian bois de capa différence
quand on leur dit mais j'ai pas ils ont
peur de nous casser peut-être fait pas
qu'est ce que vous leur dites j'allais
quand c'était un nombre qui allaitent
on dirait que ça du stand de tir n'est
pas de gymnastique à l'abord main
adieu rouge à lèvres poudrier et sac à
main désormais l'indispensable à pour
nos famas le meilleur fusil d'assaut au
monde selon certains experts
ces nouvelles amazon app landeron à le
monter le démonter et le remonter
parfois même les yeux bandés
armé en permanence quand il est en
service le cowboy comme on surnomme des
commandos est aussi le seul militaire du
rang à pouvoir tirer sans l'ordre d'un
supérieur
le premier contact n'est pas toujours
évident ça fait longtemps les
impressions mois générant dans la vanne
ou m'y habituer
ça va c'est impressionnant parce qu'on
n'a pas l'habitude à la vie courante
d'avoir une arme à la main
mais après on s'y habitue facilement
puisque on fait du tir toutes les
semaines est ce qu'on se dit qu'on va
s'en servir un jour
1c c'est quelque chose qui
qui va nous servir pour notre survie
et tu penses que tu utiliseras
commence que c'est ma vie c'est ma vie
après l'exercice retour à l'armurerie
tout le monde participe au démontage du
stand de tir même si les filles portent
plus volontiers les cibles que les
caisses d'armes au cours de ces 4
semaines de formation elles auront
participé à cette séance de tir et
griller une centaine de cartouches
les cousines partagent leur chambre avec
sabrina bilan de la journée
un peu froid mais ça va
deux jours sur le terrain au niveau
physique j'étais un peu un peu derrière
mais je me suis débrouillé je fais ce
que je pouvais faire
on vous en demande autant aux garçons
c'est difficile où on pas vraiment parce
que ça doit pas être non c'est pas aussi
dieu qu'on nous avait dit c'est pas
vraiment les tests physiques physiques
s'étaient pas montrés du
garçon sont pas gentils avec nous ils
veulent pas écouter les filles supporte
pas de répondre aux ordres des filles
alors ce matin s'est fait envoyer
balader on aller gentiment à aller
chercher en chambre pour le petit
déjeuner avant nous engueuler parce que
certains voulaient pas aller déjeuner
voulait dormir donc gueuler sur les
couloirs c'est vraiment pas
ici tout est minuté entre 19 et 20
heures direction la cantine on apprend à
vivre en collectivité on partage tous
les corvées les cours l'entraînement et
les repas
apparemment la mixité ne pose aucun
problème relationnel
elle semble même plutôt bien accueilli
quand ils ont
senti que
c'était que je choisis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
8 heures du matin le thermomètre flirte
avec le zéro degré tenue obligatoire
même par ce froid le short
les gants sont interdits
[Applaudissements]
un jour important pour la promotion tout
particulièrement pour stéphanie qui
rêvent du grand saut aujourd'hui en
effet au programme les tests physiques
qui ouvriront les portes du bea pm le
brevet d'aptitude de parachutisme
militaire
les futurs breveté rejoindront une unité
d'intervention susceptibles de partir en
mission à l'étranger les autres seront
affectés à des unités de protection ce
sont les seuls tests pour lesquels les
barèmes sont différents pour les filles
épreuve la plus redoutée par stéphanie
une traction qu'elle doit maintenir 12
secondes sortez le manteau six sortait
le menton 7 8 9 10 11
attendez la cia si
le but du jeu c'est pas de se projeter
avec le manteau sinon vous vous lâchez
les mâles c'est plus d'être un tueur ça
fait d'avoir une force des bras donc
j'allais repasser refaire un truc
correct vous n'avez pas tant pis vaut
donc certaines ne s'attendait pas à ça
sûrement donc c'est un peu surprise et
sont surtout pas préparé donc tandis que
son fils y penser un peu plus loin
3 2 à
4 km en moins de vingt-quatre minutes
pour les filles contre 20 minutes pour
les garçons c'est l'ultime épreuve
[Musique]
après le test de l'attraction stéphanie
est un peu inquiète mais elles restent
persuadés d'y arriver
26 44
venir
donc je vais jouer les tests physiques
d'aptitude osseux motivation ils
pouvaient pas sauté à lisieux
voilà donc là ce que vous faites ce que
vous retournez en chambre vous allez
vous mettre en tenue de corps à corps
pour quelques minutes de trop le soldat
stéphanie hasseni ne connaîtra jamais le
bonheur de sauter dans le vide depuis un
avion les jeux sont faits elle doit
tourner le dos à ses rêves de
parachutisme elle rejoindra une unité de
protection
pour les autres les tests continuent
courageux volontaires et résistant le
soldat tatiana hasseni a réussi ces
tests elle vaut même certains des petits
gars selon ses instructeurs
les filles évoluent au même titre que
les hommes sur sur ces différents
obstacles au contraire éventuellement
ils seront peut-être même plus guerrière
plus aguirre que les autres parce que
quelque part en l on a le sentiment
qu'elle qu'elles veulent se prouver leur
ont leur place parmi nous et donc vous
voyez par vous un exemple brillant da
ilha 80 franchir l'obstacle et les voulu
avec la même technique la même rapidité
voilà bien
sandra 21 ans un plus par rapport aux
garçons dans le civil elle a déjà
effectué 80 saut en parachute une
passion qu'elle a financé en vendant
tout ce qu'elle avait sa chaîne hi-fi sa
mobylette ce disque a tiré par l'armée
son amour du parachutisme a beaucoup
pesé dans son engagement si vous attirer
dans l'armée le déjà 7 capable de faire
un métier d'homme pour leur prouver que
nos têtes des femmes ont pu faire
lorsque mais sur ses portes et uniforme
parce que c'est quand même c'est quand
même important ce même forme s'est
défilée aussi bon la préparation ça ne
sais pas mais après quand on est dans le
défilé c'est très intéressant et puis
bien sûr partir à l'état chose c'est le
mieux quoi bon aller garçons se passe je
dirais très très bien jamais je n'ai
jamais eu un mot plus haut que l'autre
dès qu'on arrive pas faire quelque chose
ils sont là pour vous aider si on a un
coup de blues à et salut ça va ça va
passer tu vas voir
c'est le grand jour sandra un peu tendu
va faire son premier saut militaire
[Musique]
sur les treize filles de la promotion
sandra est la seule à être destiné à une
unité d'intervention
pour ce premier saut à 400 mètres
d'altitude
il dispose de deux parachutes le dorsale
qui s'ouvre automatiquement et le
ventrale qu'ils auront le droit d'ouvrir
pour ce saut
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
avec et le poids des parachutes c'est le
même que pour les garçons pas différence
mais même pas
ou bien ça peste
comme ils peuvent de temps combien
ils en ont passé des plus légers pour
les filles nos images non pardon moi je
peux reconnaître avec des garçons ils
quitteront pas dire elle ne parle plus
plus léger tout
à bord de cet avion 28 fusiliers
commandos sandra est la seule fille à
bord
[Musique]
sauf que j'ai du mal à faire gonfler la
voie du concret
elle avait passé deux prises d'air
et la différence alors avec au civil
c'est plus brutale la sortie au ciné
c'est pareil scénario c'est exactement
la même chose
sauf que ici un petit côté - quoi la
sortie de l'avion c'est à dire quand on
fait encore rire franchement voyons
le solde à hendaye a réussi son pari la
route lui est ouverte vers la baie à 106
de bordeaux mérignac elle sera la
première et la seule fille dans son
escadron
quant aux deux cousines elles vont être
affectés ensemble sur la base de
villacoublay elles ne sont déjà plus les
mêmes j'ai changé ouais ça maintenant je
suis un point à dire un dossier
et g
[Musique]
avant si on veut ce que tu veux penser
les autres quoi les sentiments des gens
je vous fous tu es maintenant on veut
dire que c'est un peu plus attention peu
plus de tact on va dire
je dirais pas que je suis devenu une
crème attention
je suis sociable gagnant
si un jour vous retournez dans la vie
civile et tous qu'est ce que vous
garderez de l'armée non mais moi
justement je me demande dans la vie
civile comme ça à faire parce que bon à
l'armée on est quand même assez proche
un
monde or là on va manger là bas il va
tous ensemble et tout ça alors que vous
on peut dire qu'on a assumé alors que
dans la vie civile - c'est nous qui
devons nous assumer ce pouvoir et si tu
veux manger frais certes et course si tu
veux dormir ou payer loyer
c'est pas la même chose là c'est comme
ça je peux soit je disais oui ça fait un
petit peu ambiance que les vacances donc
nous on a pas on n'a pas à s'occuper de
rien on fait les horn en fait on fait
notre travail puis bon à côté ba ni le
géant super de chambre ça vous fait peur
le retour à la vie civile
je pense même pas
dans le montage
dont on verra bien
deux semaines plus tard nous sommes en
bivouac près de la baie à 106 de
bordeaux mérignac sandra a rejoint son
escadron d'intervention qui stationnent
pour une série d'exercices elle commence
à jouer à la guerre pour de vrai pendant
un mois et demi encore elle va
perfectionner sa formation
[Musique]
je vous
exercice de déploiement en zone hostile
le véhicule est blindé à son bord les
fusiliers commandos sont tous armés le
but de l'exercice est de se déployer
pour quadriller le terrain et affronter
un ennemi potentiel
l'objectif est de prendre place
rapidement pour pouvoir répondre à une
attaque éventuelle sandra s'est très
vite adapté à sa nouvelle équipe
la semaine dernière n'a dormi sur le
terrain pendant neuf t3 jours on a passé
deux nuits et donc que la première nuit
on a passé sous tente donc là ça a été
mais la deuxième nuit en à passer dans
un trou puis ce qu'on devait faire une
gare de quoi et donc on était trois dans
le même trou et après bon après c'est un
nom à s'arranger notre petit confort
quoi et notre camouflage pourquoi se
repérer
19 heures la journée de travail n'est
pas terminé pour sandra c'est le
nettoyage des armes
moi je le reconnais que c'est la sienne
numéro
tu connais par coeur oui c'est quoi le
numéro 1 965
euros porte bonheur
v65 sa plaque d'immatriculation notre
pyrénées cela bouge bien
ce soir les soldats ont quartier libre
en dehors des périodes de garde les
fusiliers commandos peuvent retourner
chez eux sandra elle en profite pour
rejoindre stéphane son ami mais avant de
changer de monde sandra change de tenue
enfin j'aime bien sûr tu viens
et je passais garde à vous ou alors le
salut ou
ce genre de truc comme ça
personne écrit militaire
s'achèteront quel
retour à la maison pour sandra et
stéphane dès leur rencontre sandra n'a
jamais caché sa volonté d'intégrer un
jour l'armée de l'air
stéphane l'a toujours soutenu c'est lui
qui l'a re motive quand le moral baisse
quand elle rentre le soir et que je vois
qu'elle est quand même mâché qu'elle a
des traces de sa journée parce que c'est
pas des petites journées non plus
c'est vrai que ça fait un peu mal mais
bon je lui dis pas trop parce que faut
que je mette dans la tête que je suis
que je comprends ce que c'est que ce
métier c'est tout c'est vrai que tomber
sur des sols gelés chapeau des coudes
girafe ou des plages qui harley days et
tout ce qui se fait dans son quotidien
c'est pas assez pas évident pour une
fille mais halal mental c'est ce qui l'a
fait devenir ce qu'elle est on était
difficile de tenir sa un vrai soutien
moral à la maison mais j'ai mes parents
comme qui me soutiennent beaucoup mon
père et ma mère donc si même ça va pas
je téléphone mais beaucoup stéphane quoi
j'arrive d'avoir une présence avant le
soir et de parler de son travail de dire
ça sympa et et ça c'est dur moralement
ça il fait beaucoup là nous mais on
repart data quoi
nous sommes sur la base aérienne 132 de
colmar
au sein de son escadron de protection
sabrina effectué une patrouille destiné
à assurer la garde des avions alors là
je vérifie la clôture du parking avion
reste tout a bien cadenassé a pas de
problème
il ya des gars de nuit comme des
patrouilles de jour il s'agit de
vérifier donc les clôtures bénéficiez
pas d'individus suspects la nuit surtout
dans les les aider mais c'est zone
militaire sensible
vérifier si tous les portails sont bien
cadenassé
[Musique]
la tournée continue inspection d'un
hangar contenant des avions en
réparation
ce n'est pas la grande aventure promise
mais bon
certaines sommation à faire pour
prévenir déjà l'individu que nous sommes
là lui dire ce qui va se passer si elle
obéit pas aux sommations s'il s'arrête
pas on a droit de faire feu donc vous
tiriez s'il faut oui
sabrina vient de s'installer dans un
petit appartement avec mathieu son ami
lui et pompiers militaires sur la même
base qu'elle ce soir elle a invité ses
parents à dîner
pour brigitte sa maman ça n'a pas été
facile d'accepter la vocation de sa
fille jada vraie surprise au début bien
sûr parce que bon parce qu'on avait
vraiment pensé qu'elle allait faire
c'est vrai on avait d'autres temps
d'autres vues pour elle mais bon disons
que je choisisse et sa vie fait ce
qu'elle veut je n'aime pas qu'est ce que
vous pensiez qu'elle allait faire et ce
que vous elle dit alors est une étude
enfin on était un peu déçu oui parce que
nous on je vais vous dire franchement on
avait envie d'en faire une avocate de
2,6 passes cabot elle paraît la merci de
à s'exprimer elle se débrouillait bien
pour parler tous travaillé très bien à
l'école
mathieu et sabrina se fréquentent depuis
deux ans mathieu a toujours su que
sabrina voulait s'engager
nommé sur la même base qu'elle il doit
encaisser les plaisanteries des autres
militaires encore peu habitués à voir
des filles dans le corps des fusiliers
commandos
aimerait s'engager
à ce que vos lecteurs
je serai avec toute façon nous on quitte
à pâques n'ont peut-être pas ce
militaire vos quatre voies ferrées vous
ne sais pas quoi salah une fille bon à
fond le tennis et tout
ta femme est
toujours sage et un qu'on se croisera
sur la base femme coco et tout ça
ça c'est des scènes de mettre en place
sabrina n'a que 19 ans elle veut croire
que son engagement ne l'empêchera pas de
mener une vie normale à l'aube de l'an
2000 ces femmes soldats rêve de faire
carrière et d'avoir des enfants en même
temps ils peuvent encore continuer leur
leur carrière tous les noeuds d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'il faudrait ça serait bien
et s'il pouvait faire un petit peu mieux
bon si elle pesait là les possibilités
moi j'aimerais bien oui la fois ce sera
à elle de voir ce qu'elle veut faire au
lieu d'aller travailler au bureau ou à
l'usiné assure la basse et tout donnera
son enfant à garder peut-être à sa maman
j'espère aura pas de problème la mamie
sera là
des crèches pour les bébés des cocos ce
sera peut-être le prochain dossier à
l'étude à l'état major en
professionnalisant l'armée jacques
chirac n'y avait sans doute pas pensé